[Musique]
les métros parisiens ont le droit d'être
bondés mais les télésièges et l ess qui
sont interdits pour éviter des
attroupements
monsieur le premier ministre notre
demande est simple votre gouvernement
peut-il enfin s'engager à tout faire
pour sauver les stations quoi qu'il en
coûte
et surtout à faire enfin pris mais le
bon sens locale sur les déserts
la fermeture prolongée des remontées
mécaniques je tiens à vous le redire
n'impacte pas seulement les entreprises
liées aux sports d'hiver
c'est tout un écosystème qui s'écoule et
les finances des communes avec la saison
2020-2021 ne sera pas blanche malgré la
neige abondante mais bien noir avez vous
l'intention monsieur le premier ministre
d'organiser un cynique braquage
démocratique en détournant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire à des fins
politiciennes pour décaler les élections
locales
après la présidentielle après les
retards et les ratés les faux départs et
les couacs et pour tout dire le fiasco
du début de la campagne un million de
français ont pu être vaccinés
un million 1 % en un mois ce qui nous
laisse toujours derrière l'espagne
l'italie l'allemagne est très loin
derrière le royaume uni avec 7 millions
de vaccinés à peine parti déjà au
ralenti
pourtant les élus sont prêts les
collectivités sont prêtes les soignants
sont prêts les français sont prêts le
gouvernement est il prêt dans nos
centres il ya clairement un manque de
doses
vous avez fait naître beaucoup d'espoirs
il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
frustration description premier ministre
il est temps que vaccination rime avec
anticipation
allez vous faire confiance monsieur
ministre aux professionnels de santé de
proximité incarné par le trio médecins
infirmiers pharmaciens trio qui est au
plus près des patients les moyens
financiers sont absents et les doses ne
suivent pas
monsieur le premier ministre pour gagner
une guerre pour gagner une guerre il ne
faut pas être à court de munitions
et vous le savez comment alors croire et
justifier vos projections floués
hypothétique pour le calendrier des 15
millions de personnes vaccinées à l'été
prochain je vais vous alerter sur la
situation très préoccupante de ce qu'on
peut qualifier de désertification
pharmaceutique qui touche l'ensemble des
officines mais plus particulièrement
celle de nos territoires ruraux
ce phénomène qui accompagne la
désertification médicale aggrave le
problème de l'accès aux soins de leurs
habitants notamment les plus âgés qui de
ce fait peuvent éprouver davantage de
difficultés pour rester à leur domicile
alors que la politique des pouvoirs
publics vis-à-vis maintenir le plus
longtemps possible
mayotte est maintenant le département
français où le taux d'homicide par
habitant est le plus élevé de la
république
l'archipel est plongé dans une spirale
infernale d'assassinât et de destruction
sans réaction à la hauteur vendredi 8
janvier dernier nous avons été incité
par réseau de transport d'électricité
rte à réduire notre consommation
électrique afin d'éviter que notre
réseau soumis à un pic de consommation
ne s'effondre quel aveu de taille
lorsqu'on pense qu'en france il ya
quelques années avant l'arrivée des
socialistes ne disposions d'une
capacités excédentaires de production
électrique et qu'il faut désormais nous
serrer la ceinture
mon invoqué la larme à l'oeil la
souveraineté alimentaire et en même
temps empêcher le sénat de se prononcer
sur la ratification du c'est à ce traité
qui ouvre nos frontières aux produits
des fermes usines du canada et qui
engendre des conséquences désastreuses
pour une partie de notre production
agricole nationale où en est le
gouvernement sur l'une des réflexions
qui l'avait fléché comme prioritaires
sur les sujets aussi importants que ceux
de la décentralisation de la
déconcentration et de la différenciation
territoriales
[Musique]